reaction Fox News contributed Jason
Chaffetz and the host of The Tudor Dixon
podcast tutor Dixon is with us all right
Jason I'm going to give you first crack
at this
um I sense that a lot of Democrats very
privately they want somebody else but
they don't want RFK Jr you know that's
why I'm paying attention to Gavin Newsom
as closely as I am because I think
there's that he is probably their first
choice am I wrong
uh I think Gavin Newsom I thinks himself
is probably the first choice I would
disagree with you there that's probably
true I think there are
I I think there are millions of what I
call Kennedy Democrats I I think of them
like Reagan uh Democrats these are
people that actually believe in the
First Amendment they believe in the
Fourth Amendment they believe in fiscal
responsibility and they believe in the
Constitution they also believe in a
strong National Defense that's why when
Robert Kennedy Jr starts talking a lot
of conservatives and liberal-leaning
Republicans say yeah he's got a good
point he kind of sounds like us and he
found a home talking to people like
Thomas Massey and only in Washington D.C
can you have a hearing about censorship
and the Democrats try to censor them but
there is no room for that traditional
liberal Democrat in today's Progressive
Democratic party it's just like Bernie
Sanders predicted Joe Biden is the most
Progressive president we've ever had and
there are literally about 30 percent of
that Democratic base they don't want
anything to do with Joe Biden and the
progressives they they need to find a
home that's an opportunity for
Republicans you know tutor when I when I
do this town hall with him unlike these
these other networks that think the
host's role is to debate the candidate
I'm not running for president uh I know
he has controversial views but I want to
listen to what they are I want to hear
him out uh I I believe the audience is
smart enough and sophisticated enough
that they can determine on their own uh
whether they agree with them disagree
with them believe them don't believe him
I mean I I have a hard time
understanding why people are even
unwilling to hear another point of view
I'm not unwilling to hear other points
of view
that's the most interesting part about
that to me because this guy's a Democrat
he really is so I want to know what all
of his views are I want to understand
when he comes from that party what are
the part parts of his platform that
identify with the Democrats but the
establishment Democrats have decided he
is not the one now we're seeing
something new we've seen this on our
side we've seen them attack our
candidates we've seen them try to
destroy our presidential candidates and
even our presidents as they're in office
but now they're going after one of their
own so I'm very curious how this is
going to play with the entire base of
the Democrat Party because we've been
hearing over and over and over again
people saying well this is not Kennedy's
Democrat Party anymore this is a Kennedy
and they're trying to silence him so
what does this do to their base is there
a certain faction of them that say okay
well wait a minute I was okay with this
when it was Republicans but you can't
silence our candidates too
all right who will be exit question uh
Jason I'll start with you who will be
the Democratic party's nominee in
November 2024.
I it won't be Joe Biden it won't be
Kamala Harris I think they'll both be at
least Joe Biden will not be a candidate
by the end of this calendar year my
guess is it's Gavin Newsom and my wild
card out there potentially as a vice
president is Susan Rice it's Obama loves
her and that's my Wild Card nobody's
talking about her except me all right
but I think she might be in the mix
tutor what's your take
well I agree that Gavin Newsom wants to
be that but I will tell you that someone
else wants it really bad and that is
Gretchen Whitmer she is out there every
single day saying how wonderful she is
getting more and more attention more
puff pieces in every news magazine you
can possibly imagine so I think that she
thinks she's going to get it it'll be
interesting to see if that Democrat
Party splits and there is a chance for
RFK Jr but it's going to be tough
all right very interesting guesses on
both your sides so uh great job hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else